this week another brilliant piece of
content creation and this is more like
along the wrestling sphere there's a
podcast called call her daddy right call
her daddy
at one point became like the number one
podcast in America now number ones are
tricky because they're algorithmic base
so they judge how fast you accelerate
right in other words if you're a brand
new podcast a lot of times you can jump
to number one because not a lot of
people were listening to you and then
now you have let's say a hundred
listeners going from 0 to 100 is super
fast acceleration going from 90 200 is
not that fast acceleration so you're not
gonna get the same thing that being said
listen to by a lot of people it was on
barstool sports the girls that did it
were these two girls that just talk
about like sucking dick and [ __ ] and
like you know perfect ringer keys and
all that kind of [ __ ] it says it's one
of like the girl [ __ ] podcast very
popular genre of podcasts they get into
some beef with bar stool which I'm kind
of the reason for I told you guys
earlier I told you guys earlier I'm kind
of the reason for it we'll get to that
later but you break down what's going on
okay so in short basically important
boys finds these two girls as they're
starting the podcast he's like alright
I'll take a chance on you I'll give you
guys the thing so like they started
doing the podcast independently he's
like alright I'll pay you guys money and
they get a sign on a three-year contract
they're making half a million a year
plus like merch and all the other stuff
so they're not getting paid nothing yeah
so they're making half a mil a year
they're doing this thing after one year
they're like art we want to renegotiate
the contract we're not happy with this
they want like the IP for the show they
want more money they want all the stuff
for denoise like now we're not gonna do
it
what who pushed them to do that so this
wasn't found out till later but like as
like the time goes on they're like
trying to renegotiate more and more and
then basically it's found out that
Sophia the bride
girl is dating this guy Peter Nelson I
think this is HBO exec and and he's
dropping he's shopping their podcast
around to different places trying to get
more money for it so he goes to one jury
and they're like art will give you more
money for the podcast they're signed to
a three-year contract and they're trying
to break the contract and basically they
just stop doing these episodes for like
five weeks and cost them a bunch of
money so they stopped doing the episodes
for five weeks obviously they had like
you know pre-existing ads they may be
chalked it up to Corona Dave Portnoy
offers him a few more deals like very
lucrative deals you know I'll cut you
guys loose six months early you can have
the IP like no one gets the IP usually
that's the thing we got offered a deal
very early and the the money was [ __ ]
but my main issue was they [ __ ] you at
the beginning all these deals they the
IP is ours is what they always try to
say no you if you sign that deal you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you have to keep your
IP this is what it is so for them to
give it back Dave to give that back he
really did not have to know I own your
entire pocket swap you out it don't
matter I'll cut you loose and I'll give
you everything yeah that's generous I
want to talk to about the IP thing in a
second but but yeah they said no to the
deal they still want to go somewhere
else
Yeah right and again I don't know all
like the nuance [ __ ] I'm sure
they're back and forth Portenoy goes on
their feed yeah because he has access to
their feet and drops an episode where he
explains everything that's going on on
their feet it's so brilliant the feed of
the you know number-one podcasts yes in
the country right right they can't
access their feed they're locked out of
their feed well here's why I think
that's so brilliant cuz we've all been
in a situation where somebody can
control a narrative and you're kind of
outside of it and he can go on his I G
but now he's all you now he's now he's
telling his side of the story to the
same people that have only been getting
your side of the story right and it's so
petty that most of us wouldn't do it but
I respect anybody so much when they do
do that I love it God so he breaks that
down etc and eventually I guess
communications breakdown so then I think
barstool goes all right [ __ ] it you guys
are locked out we have you for three
years we own your IP we own
the IP I don't know how deep their
contract is maybe it's so deep that
they're not even allowed to podcast if
it's not through barstool yeah who knows
that's my question cuz like but we'll
get to we'll get to the IP discussion in
a second I just want to go back to why
I'm the cause of all this so so let's
back up I don't know over a year ago
definitely over a year ago doing my girl
year so definitely over you way over
here so this is what happens I match
with a girl in this dating site called
Riya right cute chick brunette
attractive right we talk a little back
and forth we're texting everything's
cool
she asked her I asked one one of us
asked I was maybe to me I don't know to
like let's hang out we agree to go hang
out a certain day I think it's Tuesday
we who knows doesn't matter go okay
let's go hang out it's like seven
o'clock on a Tuesday and I'm like
feeling really comfortable on my couch
and I'm just like I started watching
maybe a game I think there's a game
coming on and I was like you know what I
haven't watched a [ __ ] game in a long
time and I've been working so [ __ ]
hard I just want to like sit down and
chill tonight so I text her hey I can't
do it tonight I'm sorry my bad - you
know cancel on you this late that's on
me I'll make it up to something like
that
but I just wanted to [ __ ] watch the
game I didn't want to go on a [ __ ]
date right now to rest I want to rest
some entire guy yeah you know not to
mention I knew I was gonna be my soul
mate in the future so what am I doing
with this time right now so apparently
this is what I hear she's like in full
makeup ready to go really pissed off so
she calls this guy who's been hitting
her up non-stop but she's ain't been
ignoring like crazy there works at HBO
and is this executive named Peter
they meet up they go on a date things
linked up it's beautiful they're in love
they find their soul mates you're
welcome right he gets in her ear about
the success of the podcasts and all the
sudden tells her yo you got it lists a
year later you got a leave bar so
they're taking advantage for yet cetera
she basically I caused it she had no you
basically I calls it you know like in
the Ice Age movies were like there's
that little [ __ ] rat running around
he pushes the Acorn in the ice shelf and
then it kind of breaks yeah um you know
what's interesting is you know acorn in
the whole rap you know you want credit
for good things yeah right now you want
credit for destroying two careers wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute I
want credit for Portnoy's great content
but isn't that crazy that's super small
world right like that phrase how
hilarious is it the crazy coincidence
like in the small podcasting world that
already exists in New York yeah this
crazy event could somehow be tied back
to us like directly it's not that end
around no absence it's crazy it is a
very small world that's a crazy sequence
of events this exact is a loser it's all
adding up now that was reality different
if you decide to not watch game and you
go on the date I probably have an HBO
special by now maybe I gotta stop
[ __ ] all these execs girls you didn't
you can't put on it no I mean hansel
honor he done meet his soul mate HBO
should love you in all seriousness it's
very easy not to have sex with executive
girls because they're gay no no but
we're girls oh I heard like every
executive central got fired last week
[Laughter]
dancing nobody's grazie
I need a real estate for my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]